hey youtubers is Charlie so big news
there wheels up on Punisher season 1
they have a showrunner that's already
working on scripts they just cast the
first villain so I'm gonna do a
breakdown of that but I'm also going to
explain Ghost Rider and blade to other
really big characters that I think will
eventually see in those series so the
big news is that they've cast one of the
big villains of the season played by Ben
Barnes you may remember him from The
Chronicles of Narnia movies but he's
been in a couple other things but the
thing here's the thing there's a lot of
question as to who he's playing because
people think that it might be Bobby's
Saints who was a character not from the
comics that was made up for the 2004
Thomas Jane Punisher movie so that was
the one where John Travolta played the
villain he was a crime boss Howard st.
people felt like he was a version of
comic book manu chi from like the
welcome back Frank Ark who was a pretty
interesting villain but the way she
ended up dying was so hardcore I mean it
was Garth eNOS writing so you expected
something really crazy but she ended up
crawling to the Central Park Zoo as The
Punisher was tracking her down got her
arms and legs bit off in her scalp just
like rake to shreds and then it turned
into this much bigger mob war like she
ain't like the way her character goes
down because she doesn't have any limbs
is by like trying to cheat like gnaw on
the Punishers leg it gets so hardcore so
obviously when they did the big 2004
movie they didn't want to do something
like this is like we can't do this for
mainstream audience they had not done
Ironman yet Marvel hadn't blown up so
comic book movies were still in a really
weird place like they had just done the
Angley version of the Hulk
so imagine that's kind of where
superhero movies were at at that point
they hadn't quite got to x-men last
stand level but let's just say
creatively critically that was not a
good period for comic book films it
wasn't until Iron Man triggered this big
resurgence Christopher Nolan came along
and did the Dark Knight trilogy that was
really when like the Renaissance of
comic book movies came about so you can
understand like when they did this 2004
Punisher movie how they wanted to change
a bunch of comic book things but now
that we're doing Punisher Netflix
there's none of those concerns they can
be as faithful to hardcore Punisher
comic book characters as they want so
what might be
spinning is is benbarnes might not be
playing the Bobby st. character he is
like this really minor character he was
the son of John Travolta's character who
is also a made-up character not from the
comics so it seems a little out of
character for the Netflix series that
they're getting ready to shoot to pull
from like a really bad Punisher movie
now I wouldn't say it's like the worst
Marvel movie ever but I'm not a huge fan
of Punishers cinematic outing so far so
just be prepared for him to be somebody
different than what everybody thinks
they haven't confirmed who he's been
cast as it's just that people think that
he's the Bobby Zane character so as of
right now the only other character that
we know that the Punisher series is
going to be doing is the microchip
character who's kind of like the Oracle
birds of prey type character for
Punisher Melvin Potter would probably be
a good comparison he's like a Melvin
Potter specific to Punishers character
in the comics but they eventually end up
going against each other which is funny
because Melvin Potter is gladiator in
the comics too so I'm interested to see
what happens with both those characters
like at the end of daredevil season two
like Punisher grabbing that microchip CD
makes it seem like he's going to show up
pretty soon like oh yeah we're
definitely going to be doing this
character Punisher is going to be
tracking some people down so naturally
the mob is always a big villain in the
Punisher comics so that's what they're
going to be doing in the series so they
did the Irish mafia during daredevil
season 2 they're probably going to
retaliate and I would expect in the
larger context because the kingpin
controls most of the crime in the city
or he will really soon he'll come into
play down the road too like he'll become
a larger villain for all the Netflix
series eventually right now he's very
daredevil specific like Nelson and
Murdock are on his list
the daredevil is on his list in The
Punisher is also on his list so
eventually he's going to start
consolidating power we might only be
getting an inkling of that when the
Punisher series picks up because largely
you know like when each of these
characters gets their own first spin-off
series they have their own story and
then later on they weave in the other
Netflix characters so like you'll see
other characters crossover on the
Punisher but mostly they're going to be
telling a Punisher specific story like
it could exist by itself without the
other Netflix series but it will tie in
like it's all connected so like in about
two weeks Luke Cage
is going to drop it'll be the same thing
it'll be very Harlem specific but
because Harlem is part of New York it's
going to connect with the other Netflix
series they'll acknowledge stuff that
happened during Jessica Jones during the
daredevil season stuff that will be
happening during Iron Fist so it all
kind of bleeds together but you know
usually when characters start out in the
road series it's very self-contained but
because they're not going to start
shooting the season Punisher season 1
until the beginning of next year they're
not going to finish it for at least
they'd like you to at least the tail end
of the year so I will be blown away if
they even try to premiere during 2017 I
think it's going to be like early 2018
before we see Punisher but if they do
actually announce a release date or give
any hints as to when it's going to drop
I'll be sure to post an update it's just
the defenders is going to be happening
before Punisher season 1 for sure and
Punisher will appear on that so a lot of
what's happening with Punisher during
defenders will also inform what's
happening during Punisher season 1 so
there's like a whole bunch of story that
we'll see from Punisher that we haven't
got yet that will give us a pretty good
idea of what's going to be going on so
just be sure to watch all the Netflix
series whenever they drop so you're
asking now are there any comic book
storylines that they're going to be
doing during the Netflix series they
could totally do welcome back Frank
that's basically that Manu Chi's
storyline that I talked about earlier in
the video where you know he basically
announces his return to New York City by
killing three of the top members of that
family and is just like hey it's
open season on the Mafia Punishers back
the comic book story they did for
Punisher during daredevil season 2 was
kind of like daredevil versus Punisher
so they also weaved in trial of the
Punisher a little bit they did a little
Punisher max when he got thrown in
prison so there's a little bits of comic
book storylines but nothing's ever going
to be like an exact interpretation of a
comic book storyline there'll be things
from comic book storylines characters
but they're not going to do an exact
story from the comics it would be
awesome to see like a hearts of darkness
crossover with Ghost Rider everybody
wants to see Ghost Rider in the Netflix
series they're doing Robbie ray is on
agents of shield it looks like it's
going to be pretty cool but I totally
would not be surprised if blade or Ghost
Rider showed up in the Netflix series
eventually blade is another character
people have been asking about Wesley
Snipes is out
prison-like he's trying to work again
Marvel has the rights to do the
character they could do blade anytime
they want in the movies or in the TV
shows whenever they can work him in
they'll do it it's just that they
haven't done vampires yet so you like
you kinda have to explain that vampires
exist in this universe before you can do
blade so I think the other big thing
that's holding them back on blade is
also trying to work out a deal with
Wesley Snipes so maybe we'll see Wesley
Snipes blade come to the Netflix series
or in the movie somewhere I think it's
more likely that they would do him on
the Netflix series but let me know in
the comments would you actually want to
see Ghost Rider and blade as a Netflix
series or at least crossover with the
other Netflix series even if they didn't
get their own season I feel like that'd
be pretty badass they can do some really
good character development too because
you have two hours to develop a
character in a movie but you get almost
13 hours to do it on one of the Netflix
series so I feel like you get a lot
better payoff with the Netflix stuff
just because you have more time to spend
with those characters but get height and
there is a Marvel giveaway going on
right now all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video I'm still giving away Captain
America blu-ray so I'll announce the
winner the next time I post a Marvel
video but we just learned about Kevin
Smith's flash episode he's shooting it
right now
so I'm gonna do a video for that it will
be a really awesome
killer frost deep cut so that should
post it a little while and just a heads
up if you haven't seen my last couple of
videos YouTube rolled an update now you
can actually click on the links that I
add to the end of videos if you're on
your mobile phone but there are few bugs
that they're still working out so if you
guys do have problems clicking on those
links just let me know in the comments
it should be fine though in the next
couple days while you guys wait for that
to post you can click here for like the
last big Luke Cage trailer I just posted
and you can click here to learn all
about the new Batsuit and Justice League
the Batman is going to be where
so thank you so much watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you